we think that that post-independence  forms the Union and its purposes and the  Constitution sets up its form of  governments and we think I think that  those two things are something more than  compatible they are necessary to each  other that's very controversial and I'll  say a minute about what I'm leaving out  in these lectures but what follows if  this is true is that a human being is a  certain kind of thing and requires to be  treated in a certain way human being is  the thing that has rights and those  rights are inalienable according to the  Declaration you've got to respect them  and it also follows that given the kind  of thing the human being is government  needs to be organized in certain ways  and we think I think that that is the  argument of the American Revolution  you